[Music]
our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
and this morning we're showing you a new
approach to bridging divides in chicago
neighborhoods from the city's north and
south sides are banding together to take
on some
very deeply rooted issues the
differences between these communities
they are stark but as adriana diaz shows
us together they are tackling
segregation and the inequity that comes
with it
did you have any of those posters left
yeah i do
chicago residents nanette tucker and
wade wilson share a love of gardening
and craft beer
that would be kind of cool it would be
cool they're like neighbors
sort of wade is called your map twin why
are you guys
twins we're twins because when you
follow the map
we touch one another on the map north
and south
like many cities chicago is a grid with
many streets spanning north
to south if you fold a map of the city
in half you can match addresses on the
north side
with the same block on the south side
you lived all your life never thinking
you had a twin
and now now i have one they live about
15 miles apart
but wilson and his wife jennifer live in
the majority white north side
neighborhood of edgewater
while tucker is in the mostly black
south side neighborhood
of englewood how would you explain the
differences between both of your
neighborhoods which are
essentially equidistant from the center
but worlds apart in many ways
it's very clear that neighborhoods
primarily on the north side have had
more investment everything from the
street lighting to grocery stores and
restaurants
it's plentiful on the north side and
it's not
here it's almost like you you feel a
light
come on at a certain spot when you're
going north
and when you're coming back south
you can feel the glow that's upon us
in inglewood curiosity they met through
tonica lewis johnson
a social justice artist who grew up in
inglewood a community often in the news
two mass shootings shot in the head
shooting claims the life of a
15-year-old boy in west
englewood lewis johnson created the
folded map project
which includes this film to change the
conversation
she contrasts how the same street like
ashland avenue
they look very different looks on the
north side
the sidewalks and the south side the
maintenance of the building
none of which have anything to do with
gun violence
only disinvestment chicago segregation
is due in part to racist policies
like redlining where banks would
designate properties in minority areas
delineated in red as too risky for
mortgage lending
excluding black americans from a primary
pathway of building wealth
home ownership you have neighborhoods
that are predominantly black that have
low home ownership as a result
of the discriminatory practices
businesses left so you don't have a
business corridor so therefore you don't
have
jobs and now the schools are starting to
fail because they aren't properly funded
her solution bring the north and the
south together
with map twins it can feel so
overwhelming to try to take on
systemic racism but you have found a way
to almost chip away at it one person at
a time
one pair at a time yes let's use
segregation
as the actual thing that can connect us
in her project
she doesn't shy away from uncomfortable
truths how much
was your home it was sixty one thousand
dollars and how much was your home
five hundred thirty five thousand you
asked wade in the net what they each
paid for their house
you know it felt a little awkward i
think the awkwardness helps people
understand how we're all participating
in this system that was created before
us and it doesn't truly reflect how we
want to connect with each other today
frankly we're privileged and
it's hard to sit next to a friend who
hasn't enjoyed that privilege
we realize that there is an opportunity
to actually do something
wilson and tucker are doing something
together
three years after they met through the
folded map project with others they
created
englewood renaissance
which is helping beautify parts of
englewood and is now focusing on
increasing homeownership here creating a
community together
the economics might be different the
neighborhoods might be different
but the core of who i am is pretty much
the same as wade and jennifer i want the
same things they want for cbs this
morning
adriana diaz chicago
this is such an important story yes it
is such an important story you have the
same street and the different economic
values and
why that's happened and the difference
in the numbers anthony
61 000 versus 500 000 plus but it's a
perfect example to show that story on
the same day that we did the 110 project
exactly
because it shows you that it starts
there yes
and that's why this disparity in
pointing out the disparity
because i know there are many white
people look and say well i don't have
the privilege either
this is not asian it shows it's not
ancient history no
the legacy of these practices from the
mid-century are with us today
and they will continue to be with us
because the value of these homes is
about these homes yeah
and the question now as we become aware
of it is what are we going to do
about it and recognizing that it is an
issue
yeah it is a major problem in this
country but as long as that economic
disparity continues to exist you will
have these
these differences will persist so much
more than planning a garden together
that's very lovely
but it's so much more than